I had already had my turn in the Marvel
Universe show so now yeah now I got
drafted into the DC Universe which was
again because I don't know anything
about show business they get my agent
called and said you know Zack Snyder
wants to you know meet with you and I
was like awesome who's that you know he
looks like biggest directors and you
know probably would and but not even
like this is what it's about just like
you know go meet and so we went Matt you
know hit it off cuz you know he's a
great guy and we were like several
minutes into the meeting when he kind of
I kind of saw this quizzical look and he
gets you have no idea why you're here
dude no man I just
and he said well Commissioner Gordon I
want you to play Commissioner Gordon and
I was like oh that's awesome
that's and then immediately kind of
intimidating also you know because so
many wonderful actors have done it in
the past but it was great it was great
to get my feet wet you know in this in
the first Justice League movie the first
we say you know hoping that there will
be more that's the plan everybody you
know when you were cast as Jim Gordon I
think the number one question was like
does this mean that you could never play
a general Jameson again is that like a
thing like a contractual it's not a
contractual thing okay no although I
don't know I just feel like I would be
pissed and a lot of people would be
pissed if somebody else was playing J
John Jameson so if like if that happened
to come up would I do it i I've never
seen ever okay
I mean you know obviously I had a an
amazing time with Sam Raimi on those
movies and Toby and everybody and you
know that was that was a great great
time and I'm huge for my career in my
life and I'm just sure fun
if there were an opportunity to revisit
that I don't know though I mean how old
is spider-man gonna be if J John Jameson
is this old how come he's still so young
he's getting there's like a joke that
like Aunt May is eventually gonna be
like a 16 year old how many of you are
there
not enough you're right we have seen
iterations of doing Borden on screen so
what is what do you think something
about your Jim that's time I have to see
my normal response to a question like
that is that easy he's a bald guy that
looks like this but of course he's not a
bald guy because Jim Gordon can't be a
bald guy I you know the I can't even I
don't want to say anything about the
first film I think I think as we delve
further into Jim Gordon and in the
planned sequel what I'm hoping to find
is some of his sort of tough-guy badass
you know there there have been so many
incarnations of him you know obviously
in print and and also on screen and and
I think one of the aspects that I found
mostly interesting about him as I did my
research with my with my comic book nerd
friends mostly a tough guy there is like
an ass-kicking yeah
aspect of Jim Norton so
you
[Music]